اهل الراويه اهلا عادل تحيه طيبه لكم
ولجميع مشاهدين صباح العربيه طبعا انا
توهقت طلعت من جيزان بلبس عادي وجاه هنا
جيت في ابها وكان البرد جدا عالي يعني
نتكلم اليوم عن درجات الحراره في ابها
والباحه 16 درجه مئويه اليوم حسب ما قالها
المركز الوطني للارصاد اتحدث اليوم
في الاجواء في السعوديه طبعا بالمناسبه
اهل الباحه وابها يشعرون ان هذه الاجواء
البارده اجواء صيفيه انهم ما يشعرون انها
اجواء بارده بالمناسبه اجوائهم البارده من
تحت عشره درجه مئويه في فصل الشتاء فاليوم
احنا نتكلم عن ان هذه الاجواب بالتاكيد
انها جاذبه للزوار والسائحين الذين اتوا
اليوم الى ابها والباحه ليعيشوا هذه
التجربه ونعيش وهذه الاجواء الجميع نتحدث
اليوم ايضا انه اليوم الاثنين تنتهي
الاجازه المطوله لطلاب التعليم العام
والتطلاب التعليم الجامعي ايضا الذين اتوا
اليوم ايضا ليعيشوا هذه الاجواء الجميله
في جبال الباحه وجبال ابها المناطق
الجنوبيه هنا في السعوديه تمتاز بهذه
الاجواء المعتدله والبارده نتحدث ايضا انه
تقريبا لنا اسبوع كامل ما زالت الامطار
متواصله ونشهد اليوم ايضا استمرار لهطول
الامراض وامطار وتوقعات ايضا باستمرار
هطولها في الايام القادمه هكذا هي الاجواء
الصيفيه هنا في جنوب السعوديه هي اجواء
معتدله الى بارده محموله ايضا بالامطار
والاجواء الجميله وهذه المناظر من امامنا
الاشجار الخضراء والجو العليل اتمنى فعلا
انه يعني
في ابها والباحه انتم في صباح العربيه
ونعيش هذه الاجواء مع بعض ان شاء الله
وتكون ايامنا وايامكم جميعا رائعه وسعيده
هذا ما كان لدي من هنا
اسامه والله شكله صيفيه عندك في ابها شكرا
جزيلا وسامي القاسم مراسلنا هذه المره من
ابها لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه وال
وثائق الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات